yo dog you ready brah bobby's [ __ ] urban
Bobby house down roof dog yeah do the
countdown bro five four welcome to Tiger
belly my name is Bobby and we've got
kalila and we got Gilbert and we got
George as a pink dick and welcome to
another the 51st episode or on our
podcast podcast a podcast and I just got
back from Sacramento and thank you for
all the people from tiger belly showing
up to the show but it wasn't enough and
unnerving it was the worst week and I've
ever had there is a worst because I've
been there that Sacramento punchline
probably 20 times my life and I usually
do pretty well numbers wise this was the
worst I've ever done well the location
of that place is upstairs next to a
mattress store so it's a little bit um
you know it's not conducive for business
yeah and then they stayed they are
closed that Mongolian restaurant across
the street which I love you ever been to
a Mongolian restaurant where they cooked
in front of you yeah we have that
gigantic thing you know I love that I
lived in Mongolia in Israel how many
years sir 20 years I lived among go oh
my gosh today you're not in the Marco
Polo cast Wow
career attack right away sorry you know
I've had a really roll up I've got a
rock career week yes number one why are
you so excited cuz she likes when she
likes to rub it in my [ __ ] eyes but a
year ago about a year ago bro your boy I
auditioned for a show called Montauk
what's that
I'll tell you what it is dude i go in i
go in and i play a teacher and i did
good and then they call they go yeah we
were very interested in him so they put
me on hold for a couple of months and
then they go you know well we don't
think that there's a business and it's a
genre piece so we don't think there were
Asians in the 80s so we're gonna hire
Andrew Daly who was a friend of mine he
was on MADtv I love Andrew
but then he couldn't do it so they
called me back to see what my
availability was what you say and I'm
available
oh and then they go and then another
month went by they go no we I think
we're gonna get a white guy and the show
is called stranger things now and as a
teacher as that teacher and I didn't get
it because of my kooky eyes I could have
been in it but I didn't get it and it's
like my kooky eyes guys now were there
really no Asian teachers the in the
eighties there were but they sold opium
laundry and stuff so then that happened
and then I get invited to do oddball big
deal right egg very being Latino I look
at the flyer and my name is in tiny
little black you know in the red and
blue border right they did red oh they
did both on Regan Brian Regan Sebastian
big red me Ali Wong black little black
funk funk
I mean font Eliza slacker slashing
there's a black little black font that
fan in red and bold oh my god no we're
gonna be invited of that I'm sorry
we're too good to get a black day of all
the internally combust he would die on
the spot arranged I'm not incompetent I
love the guy what are you guys talking
about he's my I'm a big fan so you would
split an hour at oddball with that
family already Bobby okay all right but
I didn't get red font that's fine and
then um well Hopkins oh then I thought
MADtv last wait cool it all right but
one of the scenes was Ike Barinholtz
gives two of the cast members
a tour of his dressing room like oh my
god I ain't giving us a tour and then he
there's a little thing on the wall that
like a lot of thing opens and I'm living
in there and I've got a feral and
basically what happened was when the
show got cancelled I got stuck in the
wall was a big story lied behind yeah
stuck in the wall you have to see and
I've gone completely feral and but then
it's like but then I think you know what
since MADtv I could have probably just
stayed in that wallet pretty much the
way my career is done not really that's
what the joke well if you're in a wall
would you they wrote it that way you
know who wrote the sketch John
Barinholtz Oh
Ike's brother so that I am some I have
long hair I'm dirty I am go to Adam
Ray's Instagram and there's a video of
it there yeah it's so funny immediately
I watched it probably eighty without
doing it you just please watch it oh you
were feral and you're like I'm trying it
I'm trying to get a job here yeah my
point is is that then oh God it gets
worse it gets really worse so then I am
I forget I can is funny but no I'm not
gonna buy anybody and then I went to the
Sacramento punchline this weekend it was
pretty bad so I've had a tumultuous week
but you know what guys I'm not gonna
give up boom I'm gonna do the oddball as
black font
I'm gonna go armed you know dude I'm
gonna host MADtv next Friday with my Ike
live next right this Friday this coming
Friday I mean live are we Co are we
going can we you're gonna go can Gilbert
and Georgie come with me they want to
come they can come yeah 100% you can be
my aunt cheese we're on food entourage
and then but you're gonna come to
oddball kalila because people have been
requesting to do a little um blog vlog
when I'm there backstage because
have a panic attack oh yeah me so you're
gonna cut me do that and then why are
you gonna have a panic attack
inaudible because it's you know I never
do well in front of more than ten
thousand people in a crowd
oh I thought you killed that one giant
crowd that black show you said you came
out where you said you bombed they then
you did it again and you killed there's
some story your time yeah is the same
that's when you followed Leslie Jones
yeah there's the first time and I bombed
and then the next week it's fine it's
just difficult okay Gabriel I'm a game
[Music]